I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你主持“办公室重温终极版”播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事人才知道的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Hello. Office Ladies. Office Ladies. Office Ladies. Office Ladies. Hello. Hi there. Oh boy. We have a very special guest on Office Ladies today. Oh boy is right. It is John Krasinski. Woo woo. Oh yeah.
大家好。办公室女士。办公室女士。办公室女士。办公室女士。大家好。嗨。哦天哪。今天我们有一位非常特别的嘉宾做客办公室女士。哦天哪，说得对。他就是约翰·卡拉辛斯基。呜呼。噢耶。
We are so excited to have John back on the podcast again. So I was thinking, Jenna, the last time he was on was Casino Night, right? Yeah. What a fun interview. That was just so much fun. I remember when we were talking to him, I was just smiling ear to ear. Well, if you haven't heard that interview, everyone, definitely go back and give it a
我们非常高兴约翰再次来到播客。我在想，詹娜，他上一次来是《赌场之夜》吧？是的。多么有趣的采访。真的太有趣了。我记得当时和他谈话时，我笑得合不拢嘴。好吧，如果大家还没听过那次采访，一定要回去听一
listen, because John shares some amazing stuff about making Casino Night. That was a huge Jim Pam episode. Yeah. And during that interview, I remember we laughed, we cried, and I have to tell you, John is just as charming and wonderful this time around. Yes, and guess what? Once again, we laughed and we cried.
听，因为约翰分享了许多关于制作《赌场之夜》的精彩内容。那是吉姆和帕姆非常重要的一集。是的。在采访期间，我记得我们笑了，我们哭了，我必须告诉大家，约翰这次依然迷人又精彩。是的，你猜怎么着？我们再次欢笑，也再次落泪。
We are such softies, the three of us. My goodness. But it was such a joy having John on. We are such softies, the three of us, my goodness. But it was such a joy having John on. We talk about season nine, plus we reminisce about, well, just everything about the show. We got a little nostalgic again. We did, but we also got to talk with him about his new movie, If, because John produced,
我们三个人真是多愁善感。天哪。不过能邀请到约翰来真的太开心了。我们三个人真是多愁善感，天哪。不过能邀请到约翰来真的太开心了。我们聊到了第九季，还回忆了……嗯，关于这部剧的一切。我们又变得有点怀旧了。确实如此，但我们也和他聊了他的新电影《分分钟第一季》（IF），因为约翰担任了这部电影的
wrote, and directed this movie. I have seen the trailers. It looks so delightful and charming and full of heart and laughs. It basically is just John as a movie. Yeah. It's really so sweet. So here's how it's described. It's a live-action animated fantasy comedy film about a young girl named B. And she's gone
制片人、编剧和导演。我看过预告片了。看起来太温馨、迷人、充满爱心和欢笑了。它基本上就是约翰本人的电影化身。是的。真的很甜蜜。以下是它的剧情简介：这是一部真人结合动画的奇幻喜剧电影，讲述了一个叫比的小女孩。她经历了一
through a difficult time and she unexpectedly gains the ability to see people's imaginary friends, referred to as IFs for short. And I guess they've been abandoned by the kids they helped. So B discovers also that her neighbor, Cal, has the same ability, and they join forces and go on this adventure to reunite IFs with their former kids. It's really a sweet movie. And there's an amazing cast. I mean, okay, so B, the little girl, is played by Kaylee Fleming. Cal, the neighbor, is Ryan Reynolds.
段困难的时期，并意外获得了看到人们想象中的朋友的能力，简称IF。我猜他们被曾经帮助过的孩子们抛弃了。比还发现她的邻居卡尔也有这种能力，于是他们联手展开了一场冒险，让IF们与从前的孩子们重新团聚。这真的是一部很甜的电影。而且演员阵容非常强大。我是说，比，那个小女孩，由凯莉·弗莱明扮演。邻居卡尔由瑞安·雷诺兹扮演。
But then all the imaginary friends are voiced by different actors, including Steve Carell. Steve Carell, hello. John and Steve got to reunite for this movie. And you know we had to ask him all about that. Let's take a quick break. And then we come back with our interview with John Krasinski. And listen, you might want to grab some tissues. I'm just warning you.
然后所有想象中的朋友都由不同的演员配音，包括史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，你好。约翰和史蒂夫在这部电影中重聚了。你知道我们一定会问他这方面的事。我们先休息一下。然后回来采访约翰·卡拉辛斯基。听着，你可能需要准备一些纸巾。我先警告你。
I mean, lady, if we ever do Office Ladies Tangents, the podcast, we gotta get John to be our co-host. We do go on a lot of tangents, but it was so delightful. And we ask him the cast and crew call sheet questions. All right, we'll be right back. And it's happening. And it's happening. And it's happening. It's happening. You guys, what is going on?
我是说，女士们，如果我们以后要做《办公室女士》衍生播客，我们一定得让约翰来当我们的联合主持人。我们确实经常扯远，但这太美妙了。我们还问了他演员和剧组通告单上的问题。好了，我们马上回来。事情要发生了。事情要发生了。事情要发生了。事情要发生了。各位，这到底是怎么回事？
When was the last time I saw you? Oh my gosh. Well, the last time we spoke on office ladies was at the very beginning of the pandemic for casino night. Oh my God. I can't. And you guys are almost done? Yes.
我上次见你是什么时候？哦天哪。嗯，我们上次在《办公室女士》上说话还是在大流行刚开始时的《赌场之夜》。噢天哪。我受不了了。你们快结束了吗？是的。
Oh my, I'm getting emotional just thinking about that. How are you guys preparing? It's very weird. Yeah. It really is. It's like ending the show all over again. It's all the feels. I bet.
天哪，一想到这个我就情绪激动。你们是怎么准备的？这感觉很诡异。是的。真的就像把这部剧重新结束了一遍。百感交集。我敢说是的。
Yeah. Don't even get me started because I will start weeping immediately. We'll talk about all those things today. You guys are amazing. This show is amazing. It's just the best. Brings so many people so much joy. People talk to me about it all the time and I'm like, I have nothing to do with it. So good luck. Well, you're here now and we're going to talk about your movie that's coming out on Friday. John, I am so excited for this movie.
是的。别让我开始，因为我会立刻哭出来。我们今天会聊到所有这些事情。你们太棒了。这部剧太棒了。简直是最好的。给这么多人带来了那么多快乐。人们总是跟我谈论它，而我总是说，这跟我没关系。所以祝你们好运。好吧，你现在来了，我们要聊聊你周五上映的电影。约翰，我太为这部电影兴奋了。
Oh my god, you guys are the best. That you wrote, you directed it, if. I did, the movie's if, yes. I wrote it for my kids. Oh, my heart. I just figured. Oh boy, there she goes, Angela's out. Bye, heart.
哦天哪，你们太棒了。你编剧并执导的电影《IF》。是的，电影就是《IF》。我是为我的孩子们写的。哦，我的心。我早猜到了。哦天哪，她开始了，安吉拉沦陷了。再见，心脏。
The minute you're like, I wrote it for my kids. I'm like, he's such a good dad. Well, I did it to prove I was a good dad to them later. It's really just an archival. Um, no, I, uh, I had the idea a long time ago to do something with imaginary friends, but I didn't quite know what it was. You guys know, I would say to Emily all the time, I just, I wish we could go wherever it is they go just what it was. You guys know, I would say to Emily all the time, I just, I wish we could go wherever it is they go, just for a minute. You know what I mean? Where they go into those unbelievable sort of vortexes where they're having so much fun, but it's so real, and it's so genuine, and they're not being silly, they're being themselves, and you just feel like,
你一说“我是为我的孩子们写的”，我就觉得，他真是个好爸爸。好吧，我这么做是为了证明以后我在他们眼里是个好爸爸。这真的只是一个资料留存。呃，不，我，呃，很久以前就有一个想法，想拍一部关于想象中的朋友的电影，但我不太清楚具体该怎么拍。你们知道的，我总是对艾米莉说，我真希望我们能去他们去的地方，哪怕只是一分钟……你们知道的，我总是对艾米莉说，我真希望我们能去他们去的地方，哪怕只是一分钟。你知道我的意思吗？他们进入那些难以置信的漩涡，玩得那么开心，又是那么真实，那么纯真，他们不是在假装傻气，而是在做自己，你会觉得，
oh man, I wish I could meet my kids in that place one day. And then COVID hit. And all of a sudden, that place that they were going started to falter a little bit. And I could see that they were getting nervous. And they started asking me questions like, are we going to be okay? And is everything all right? And I thought, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, we can't do this. I have to make sure that they know that even on their good days or their bad days, that world exists, that world is there for them. All they got to do is turn around and head right back. And so I decided
天哪，真希望有一天我能在那个地方遇见我的孩子们。然后新冠疫情爆发了。突然之间，他们常去那个地方开始有点摇摇欲坠了。我能看出他们开始感到紧张了。他们开始问我一些问题，比如我们没事吧？一切都好吗？我想，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，我们不能这样。我必须确保他们知道，无论是在他们状态好的时候还是坏的时候，那个世界都是存在的，那个世界就在那里等着他们。他们只需回过头去，径直走回去就行了。所以我决定
to sit down and write the script and I wrote it over over the pandemic. Um, I am choked up. I have a lump in my throat. That's so beautiful. Oh my god. You guys, you guys are going to be the best audience. I can't wait for you to see this movie. I can't even talk. I can't even talk. Oh my God. It's so sweet. It's so loving.
坐下来写剧本，我是在大流行期间写的。呃，我哽咽了。我喉咙里像堵了东西。太美了。哦天哪。你们，你们会是最棒的观众。我迫不及待想让你们看这部电影了。我都说不出话来了。我都说不出话来了。哦天哪。太甜了。太有爱了。
I can't wait for people to see this movie. I can't wait for you guys to see it. It was such an amazing process because I've said this before, but it's so true. I think my kids thought I was an accountant because the only thing that they had heard rumblings of was that I worked at an office. And then they saw Emily in like Mary Poppins and Jungle Cruise. So they were like, we know what she does.
我迫不及待想让大家看这部电影。我迫不及待想让你们看。这是一个非常美妙的过程，就像我以前说过的那样，但这是真的。我想我的孩子们以前以为我是个会计师，因为他们听到的唯一风声就是我在办公室工作。然后他们看到艾米莉演了《欢乐满人间》和《森林奇航》。所以他们就想，我们知道她是干什么的。
And she was very nice to marry an accountant. And I was like, no, guys, I actually do stuff too. And so when I had the idea for this movie, I did this thing where I brought them in really early, and I pitched him the idea, and then I started telling him about the characters as I thought of them, and I showed them the early drawings, and then his artist drawings started coming in, I showed them, and that went all the way up to,
而且她嫁给一个会计师真是太好了。而我说，不，孩子们，其实我也做点别的。所以当我有了这部电影的想法时，我做了一件事，我很早就把他们叫来，把这个想法讲给他们听，然后随着我想象中的角色逐渐成形，我开始向他们介绍这些角色，我给他们看早期的草图，然后艺术家的画作也陆续出来了，我拿给他们看，这个过程一直持续到，
like, a couple weeks ago, we got prototypes of the toys, and I gave them to the girls, and it was amazing. They were like, oh, my God, this is amazing. And I said, what would you change? And they were like, his belly could be a little softer when I hug him. And I was like, okay, good note. And sure enough, they changed the toys and stuff. So it's been a family process.
比如，几周前，我们拿到了玩具的原型，我把它们交给了女孩们，这太棒了。她们说，哦，天哪，这太棒了。我说，你们会改变什么？她们说，当我抱他的时候，他的肚子可以再软一点。我说，好吧，好意见。果不其然，他们改了玩具之类的东西。所以这是一个家庭参与的过程。
However, they have not seen the movie yet. And I'll be honest with you, I have never been more terrified to show two people anything in my life. This is the absolute sweetest thing that it was a family thing. And I just, I know what that's like. When your kids are old enough and you can kind of try to, you get to share your, what you do with your kids.
不过，他们还没看过这部电影。说实话，我这辈子从来没有对向两个人展示任何东西感到如此害怕。这是一件绝对最甜蜜的事情，这是一场家庭活动。我懂那种感觉。当你的孩子足够大，你可以试着去分享，你能够与你的孩子们分享你所做的事情。
Yeah. Well, I'm in that magic window. They're in the perfect age right now where they're gonna care. And I knew that if I did a movie for them in like three or four years they'd be like, please stop. Stop trying to stop trying to beg for our attention. So I just thought this is the magic window and it's great and so we're doing a kind of a family premiere. One of the main characters is purple so we're doing like a purple carpet and everything so we're doing this whole little family. We're pretending it's the premiere and I keep
是的。嗯，我正处于那个神奇的窗口期。他们现在正处于完美的年龄，会去在乎。我知道如果我在三四年后再为他们拍一部电影，他们会说，请停下。别再试图引起我们的注意了。所以我只是觉得这是个神奇的窗口期，这太棒了，所以我们在搞一个家庭首映式。其中一个主要角色是紫色的，所以我们在搞一条紫色的地毯和各种活动，我们正在举办整个小型的家庭活动。我们假装这就是首映礼，我一直
saying don't tell them it's not the real premiere, please. Right, right. Luckily they'll never know because this isn't in public, so that's fine. John, did you have an imaginary friend growing up? I did have an imaginary friend. I had this imaginary friend and it's so funny because only in talking about my imaginary friend
说，别告诉他们这不是真正的首映礼，拜托。好吧，好吧。幸运的是，他们永远不会知道，因为这不是公开的，所以没关系。约翰，你从小有想象中的朋友吗？我确实有一个想象中的朋友。我有过一个想象中的朋友，这太搞笑了，只有在采访中谈到我的
in an interview did I realize that he might be the one who's directing all the movies Because his name was Sam brace my brother had braces at the time and I thought they were the coolest I Would find out eight years later. They were not the coolest but for a minute there braces were the thing in my world so his name was Sam brace and He and I would go to the video store which was like six blocks away or eight blocks away. And so Sam Brace and I would walk to the video store to pick out a movie enacting that movie. So we did action movies, horror movies because I was too scared to watch horror movies so I just pretended. And we just went with werewolf which was sort of the
想象中的朋友时，我才意识到他可能是那个指导所有电影的人，因为他的名字叫萨姆·布雷斯（Sam brace），我哥哥当时戴着牙套，我觉得那酷极了。八年后我才发现，其实一点也不酷。但在当时那一刻，牙套是我的世界里最酷的东西，所以他的名字叫萨姆·布雷斯。我和他会去录像带租赁店，大概有六个街区或八个街区远。所以萨姆·布雷斯和我步行去录像带租赁店挑选一部电影，并现场模仿那部电影。所以我们拍过动作片、恐怖片，因为我太害怕看恐怖片了，所以我就假装看。
de facto scary thing. And we ran away from werewolves. We were in action scenes and we're back to back as we saw in movie posters, just having each other's back. That's what we did. Aw, Sam's great. I love Sam. Sam braces. Sam is great. Braces were the coolest thing. I remember my friend had a retainer and I took a paper clip and I unwrapped it and put it on my... What? Why? I wore a paper clip. I also did that. Yeah. I did that too. Turns
我们只是选了狼人，这可以说是事实上的恐怖担当。我们从狼人手下逃跑。我们在动作戏中，背靠背，就像电影海报里那样，互相支持。这就是我们做的事。啊，萨姆太棒了。我爱萨姆。萨姆·布雷斯。萨姆太棒了。牙套是最酷的东西。我记得我朋友戴保持器，我拿了一个回形针，把它拆开然后戴在我的……什么？为什么？我戴过回形针。我也这么做过。是的。我也这么做过。事实
out retainers don't have that weird metal taste that makes you sick, but paper cups do. And they poke you in the gums. We are so tickled that you're working with Steve Carell again. Steve plays the, who's that? Steve Carroll. Oh Steve. Oh, Steve. Oh, Steve's Carroll. Yeah, fast-paced cream store in the world. Yeah. And he plays the character Blue. Can you tell us what it was like to work with Steve again after all those years? Oh my God. Well, first of all, I wrote it with him in mind, which was really amazing because clearly
证明，保持器没有那种让你恶心的奇怪金属味，但回形针有。而且它们会扎到你的牙龈。我们很高兴你能再次与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作。史蒂夫扮演的是……那是谁？史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。哦，史蒂夫。哦，史蒂夫。哦，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。是的，世界上节奏最快的奶油店。是的。他扮演蓝色这个角色。能跟我们讲讲时隔多年再次与史蒂夫合作是什么感觉吗？哦天哪。首先，我写这个剧本时心里想的就是他，这真的很奇妙，因为显然
as an actor, he's as talented as it comes. I think he's the funniest person I've ever met in my life. So that wasn't hard to write for him, but it was also weird. I would laugh extra hard while writing, thinking of like my friend Steve saying these things. And then it would immediately bring me back to the set of The Office.
作为一名演员，他的才华无可挑剔。我认为他是我见过的最搞笑的人。所以为他写剧本并不难，但也很奇怪。我在写作时会笑得格外大声，一想到我的朋友史蒂夫会说这些话。然后这会立刻把我带回《办公室》的片场。
And I would remember deliveries of not only his lines in the show, but lines off camera, like bits that he would do. And I was like, oh my God, he's gonna be great in this moment, blah, blah, blah. Had no idea that he was going to do it. And so, you know, when you asked me what it was like to work with him, I think in my head, I thought it's going to be just like the office. It's going to be a laugh a minute.
我会记起他不仅是剧中的台词，还有镜头外的台词，比如他会做的一些即兴表演。我就想，哦天哪，他在这场戏里一定会表现得很棒，诸如此类。我完全不知道他会不会接演。所以，当你们问我跟他合作是什么感觉时，我想我脑子里想的是，这会和《办公室》一模一样。肯定每分钟都有笑料。
And the dude walks in, we have this video that we put out last week of him actually walking in, which was adorable. But then as soon as we started working, instead of, I had this huge grin on my face and tears were coming out of my eyes because he went into this whole speech about how proud he is of me and how he's watched everything I've directed and that he couldn't be more proud
然后那家伙走进来，我们上周发布了一段他走进来的视频，超级可爱。但我们一开始工作，我不仅没有咧着嘴大笑，反而热泪盈眶，因为他开始长篇大论地说他为我感到多么骄傲，他看了我导演的所有作品，他感到无比骄傲，
and he feels like a brother and I was like, brr. So the first day that I thought I'd be laughing my head off, I was just reaching for tissues, all of that. He was so unbelievably sweet and kind. And then he was nice about the script and everything. And kind of as I was saying, the movie's not just a zany kind of movie about imaginary friends.
他觉得我们就像亲兄弟一样，我就想，呃。所以，本以为我会笑得前仰后合的第一天，我却一直在找纸巾，诸如此类。他真的难以置信地甜美和友善。然后他对剧本和一切都很好。就像我刚才说的，这部电影不仅仅是一部关于想象中的朋友的疯狂电影。
It's about coping and getting through, you know, difficult times and who do you turn to for that and stuff. And he was just so into the idea of it and he was just so excited to be a part of it. So it was, my short answer long is, it was one of the greatest things ever. And it was so much fun to see him again. I realized I hadn't seen him in years physically.
它是关于如何应对和度过艰难时期的，你知道的，遇到困难时你会向谁求助之类的。他非常喜欢这个创意，也非常兴奋能参与其中。所以，长话短说，这是有史以来最棒的事情之一。再次见到他真的太有趣了。我意识到我已经好几年没在现实中见过他了。
I mean, we had done that thing during COVID too on some good news, but that's the last time I had really seen him. And then he was so hilarious. But I will say, fun story, the last day we recorded him, I secretly told the lead girl who is one of the most talented people you will ever meet in your life. Her name is Kaylee Fleming. Kaylee waits till the last week of shooting this movie, which was something like
我的意思是，我们在疫情期间通过“美好新闻”做过那次节目，但那是最后一次真正见到他。然后他太搞笑了。不过我要说个趣事，我们录制他戏份的最后一天，我秘密告诉了女主角，她是你这辈子能遇到的最有才华的人之一。她叫凯莉·弗莱明。凯莉直到拍摄这部电影的最后一周才说，大约是
55 days or something. And she kept saying to me every night, I'm going to go home and have pizza. And I was like, Wow, you just go home every night and have pizza, I wish I could do that. And her mom finally goes, why don't you tell her what else do you do every night? And I said, what else do you do? And she goes, I eat pizza and I watch The Office. And I went, what's that?
第55天左右。她每天晚上都对我说，我要回家吃披萨。我说，哇，你每天晚上都回家吃披萨，我希望我也能那样。她的妈妈终于走过来问，你为什么不告诉她你每天晚上还做什么？我说，你还做什么？她说，我吃披萨，还看《办公室》。我说，什么？
She had not told me that she even knew what The Office was the entire time we knew each other. And so then she finally says, I watch it every night, it's one of my favorite shows. She was so classy and cool about the whole thing. And I said, well, that's amazing. Do you want a selfie? And she went, no, I'm good. And it was, oh my gosh, she's so cool. She was so cool. But then of course we took a selfie because I needed one.
在我们认识的整个过程中，她甚至没有告诉我她知道什么是《办公室》。然后她终于说，我每天晚上都看，这是我最喜欢的节目之一。她对待整件事表现得非常优雅和酷。我说，太棒了。你想来自拍一张吗？她却说，不用了，我挺好的。天哪，她太酷了。她太酷了。不过当然最后我们还是拍了自拍照，因为我需要一张。
But then what I did was I overlapped Steve on her day to come in and do ADR. And so she walked into the studio and saw Steve Carell and turned into dust. She just went and turned into dust right in front of him, who is so adorable. And of course he was so sweet. And I don't know, I like watching people have their days made, makes me smile.
但接下来我做的是，我让史蒂夫和她撞期，那天她来做后期配音（ADR）。所以她走进录音室，看到了史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，然后整个人当场石化了。她就在他面前石化了，这太可爱了。当然他也非常温柔。我不知道，我喜欢看别人梦想成真的样子，这让我微笑。
We know that about you, that's true. And you make a lot of people's day too, you do. You do. Oh man, you guys, I gotta come on this more often. You guys really make a lot of people's day too. You do. You do. Oh man. You guys, I gotta come on this more often. You guys really make me feel good. This is great. It's easy because you're such a loving kind person
我们了解你，确实如此。你也让很多人的这一天变得美好，你确实做到了。你确实做到了。哦天哪，伙计们，我应该更常来这个节目。你们确实让很多人的这一天变得美好了。你们确实做到了。你们确实做到了。哦天哪。伙计们，我应该更常来这个节目。你们真的让我感觉很好。这太棒了。这很容易，因为你是一个那么有爱心、善良的人，
and this movie is such a reflection of that. It really is. I'm like getting choked up again and that's ridiculous. I don't know, Jenna, is this like hormonal? I don't know. No, I was getting choked up too. So I don't know what's happening. To be honest though, Angela, be honest.
而这部电影就是这种特质的写照。确实如此。我又开始哽咽了，这太荒谬了。我不知道，詹娜，这就像是荷尔蒙引起的吗？我不知道。不，我也在哽咽。所以我也不知道怎么回事。说实话，安吉拉，说实话。
We used to get choked up all the time. I'm a crier. I'm a crier. I will cry at the drop of anything. Yeah. And Angela would tell me anything about like when you first had a baby, we were talking about it. And I would weep.
我们以前经常哽咽。我是个爱哭鬼。我是个爱哭鬼。我遇到一点小事就会哭。是的。安吉拉会跟我讲任何关于你刚生完孩子的事，我们当时在聊这个。我就会哭。
I would weep. This is true. Oh my God. It was just so great. Cause we used to say you were my kid sister. Yes. Remember that? Yes. Are you kidding? People, we've shared that on the podcast now, people, they really love that. And John, for our book, I found a picture of me with my kid sister doll. Nope. Yep. And we're almost the same height, you know, and it's in front of the Christmas tree.
我会哭。这是真的。哦天哪。这真是太棒了。因为我们以前常说你是我的小妹妹。是的。还记得吗？是的。你在开玩笑吗？大家，我们现在已经在播客里分享过这个了，大家都非常喜欢。约翰，为了我们的书，我找到了一张我和我的小妹妹娃娃的合影。没有？有。我们俩身高几乎一样，你知道的，就在圣诞树前面。
the same height, you know, and it's in front of the Christmas tree. And we put it in the book. Yeah. Because we shared that story. I know I love it so much. Okay. One other reunion we really wanted to talk about was this. I mean, epic. It like it shorted out the internet, this epic reunion with Randall
身高几乎一样，你知道的，就在圣诞树前面。我们把它放进了书里。是的。因为我们分享了这个故事。我知道我太喜欢了。好的。我们要聊的另一个重聚是这个。我的意思是，史诗级。这简直让互联网短路了，你和兰道尔·帕克这次史诗般的重聚。
Park that you guys did. How great was that? That was brilliant. John, I was, I couldn't even believe it. First of all, it blew up my phone. I don't know what happened to your phone when that dropped, but every person I've ever met ever was texting it to me. Yeah, because it was amazing.
有多棒？太精彩了。约翰，我简直不敢相信。首先，我的手机直接爆了。当那个视频发布时，我不知道你的手机怎么样，但我认识的每一个人都在给我发信息。是的，因为太棒了。
I just blacked out. When it came out, I just blacked out. So I lost all circuitry. No, that was a genius idea by Ryan Reynolds and his crew over at Maximum Effort. They do all this incredible marketing as I'm sure everybody knows. And so when it came time for the Super Bowl we were talking about ideas and they came up with this idea and said would you ever be cool with us
我当时直接大脑一片空白。当它发布时，我直接大脑一片空白。所以我所有的电路都短路了。不，那是瑞安·雷诺兹和他在Maximum Effort的团队的一个天才主意。正如大家所知，他们做了所有这些不可思议的营销。所以当超级碗来临之际，我们在讨论创意，他们想出了这个主意，并问你是否介意我们
revisiting the whole bit with Randall Park and I thought that is so funny. And then the fact that it was about IF and that IF was in there and they basically did the exact same bit as the office but as if he was about If and that If was in there and they basically did the exact same bit as the office, but as if he was the director and that just, he's so great. He's so great. He's so great, John. And it was like seamless because, you know, you had had your first kind of like big promo
重新演绎和兰道尔·帕克的整个桥段，我觉得这太搞笑了。然后事实是它是关于《IF》的，IF也在里面，他们基本上完全复制了《办公室》里的那个桥段，但就像他是导演一样，他太棒了。他太棒了。他太棒了，约翰。而且感觉天衣无缝，因为，你知道的，你之前已经发布了第一支关于电影的
come out for the movie and I watched it several times because it was so entertaining and you and Ryan Reynolds are so funny. Yeah, you have great chemistry. several times because it was so entertaining and you and Ryan Reynolds are so funny in this promo. Yeah, you have great chemistry. And so then when the Randall Park version came out and he was literally like redoing all of your bits and mannerisms and deliveries, it was incredible. And gestures? Yeah. Yeah. The one that I loved the most is when he turned and pretended to laugh just like me.
大型宣传片，我看了好几遍，因为太有趣了，你和瑞安·雷诺兹在这支宣传片里太搞笑了。是的，你们很有化学反应。看了好几遍，因为太有趣了，你和瑞安·雷诺兹在这支宣传片里太搞笑了。是的，你们很有化学反应。然后当兰道尔·帕克版本出来时，他简直就像是在重做你的所有桥段、神态和台词风格，这太不可思议了。还有手势？是的。是的。我最喜欢的是他转过身去，假装笑得跟我一模一样。
And I was like, that's freaky. That's like freaky. It's so good. Yeah. We had also just watched Andy's Ancestry because we're in season nine now. Oh my God. And so it was like, wait, what? What is happening? Yeah. Ugh. That's true. It was just a collision of everything all at once. You guys, you're in the final season.
当时我就想，这太诡异了。简直诡异极了。太棒了。是的。我们当时也刚看完《安迪的族谱》，因为我们现在看到第九季了。哦天哪。所以当时的感觉就像，等等，什么？发生什么了？是的。呃。确实。这简直是所有事情一下子碰撞在了一起。伙计们，你们已经进入最后一季了。
I know. We're in season nine. We are in the home stretch. There is so much happening right now. It's the big Jim Pam arc, like testing their marriage and Jim's in Philly and Brian the Boom guy is gazing at Pam. And Brian the Boom guy I forgot he longingly looks at Pam he's like booming yeah and he's looking at her. Yeah, there's a lot of gazing. Gazing. Didn't love it by the way. Didn't love it. I mean the performance was yeah, yeah, they did not love that. No, it's so funny when you guys, because I was texting with you, Jenna, about the last
我知道。我们在第九季。我们正在冲刺阶段。现在发生了太多事。这是吉姆和帕姆的主线，比如考验他们的婚姻，吉姆在费城，而爆炸头布赖恩正深情地凝视着帕姆。而爆炸头布赖恩，我差点忘了，他深情地看着帕姆，他在录音，是的，他在看着她。是的，有很多凝视。凝视。顺便说一句，不太喜欢。不太喜欢。我是说表演是，是的，是的，他们不太喜欢那个。不，当你们看到时太搞笑了，因为我和你发过短信，詹娜，关于最后一
season. That was such a wild experience for so many reasons. Again, you guys, I'm sure, talked about all your stuff. So I want to hear how you guys feel about it. But I remember, well, first of all, I think people know that we weren't even necessarily coming back for not like we had to all be asked if we wanted to do another season and this whole thing. And I remember that was super crazy.
季。由于种种原因，那是一次非常疯狂的经历。同样，我确信你们讨论过你们的所有经历。所以我想听听你们对此有什么感受。但我记得，首先，我想人们知道我们甚至不一定是为了……不是说我们必须都被询问是否想拍另一季以及整件事。我记得那超级疯狂。
And we all said we wanted to do it. And I think the idea to end the show was such a great idea, only because you want to go out with this bang where you can control the end of the narrative. And I think it's what allowed us to do the Jim Pam thing. Because, Jenna, you and I were talking. I think Greg and I were discussing what should happen. And I said, I just love this idea. Again, it was all Greg all the time. But when we were talking, I said to him, I love this idea
我们都说想拍。而且我认为结束这部剧的想法是一个绝妙的主意，仅仅是因为你想以一种你可以控制叙事结局的方式轰轰烈烈地收场。我认为这正是让我们能够演绎吉姆和帕姆情节的原因。因为，詹娜，你和我当时在谈论。我想格雷格和我当时在讨论应该发生什么。我说，我太喜欢这个主意了。再次说明，这全都是格雷格的主意。但当我们谈话时，我对他说，我太喜欢这个主意了
about doing something real with a couple. You know what I mean? Like one person in the couple has this huge ambition. And the other person wants to support that ambition. And yet it sort of steps on their whole existence in a way and how do you navigate that? You know what I mean? How do you support your partner in the biggest way but also maintain individuality for yourself? And I thought that was such a great thing for us to do so that it wasn't just starry-eyed, us always looking at each other. And I just, I loved it. I mean, it got uncomfortable, I'm sure, for the audience at times, but it was very real. And I know I've had people come up to me and say like, my partner goes to Cleveland two weeks out of the month
关于在情侣身上做一些真实的事情。你知道我的意思吗？比如情侣中的一个人有巨大的雄心壮志。而另一个人想要支持这种雄心壮志。然而这在某种程度上侵占了他们的整个生活，你该如何驾驭这一点？你知道我的意思吗？你如何以最大程度支持你的伴侣，同时也为自己保持个性？我认为这对我们来说是一件很棒的事情，这样它就不会只是满眼小星星、我们总是含情脉脉地看着彼此。我真的，我很喜欢它。我的意思是，这有时肯定会让观众感到不舒服，但它非常真实。我知道有人走过来对我说，我的伴侣一个月里有两周要去克利夫兰
or whatever, you know, I mean, that people live apart for so long, it's a real thing. So I loved that side of it, for sure. I didn't love not doing scenes with you, Jenna, but I do remember we did a couple phone calls and stuff that were intense. Yes, yes. And there are a few episodes where you're back in the office.
或者诸如此类的事，你知道我的意思，人们分居这么久，这是现实中会发生的事情。所以当然我很喜欢那一部分。我确实不喜欢不能和你一起拍戏，詹娜，但我确实记得我们通过几次电话之类的，都很激烈。是的，是的。有几集你回到了办公室。
And I feel like I can see it's not just Pam that's excited to have Jim back. I'm like, Oh my gosh, my scene partner face to face. Yes. We did get a few scenes together, which was always nice. It was always nice. And so I sort of had that feeling in the last season that I was coming back home, that I was like coming back to my, to this person, you know what I mean? My person that I was gone through this whole thing with. And you're totally right. It wasn't just like doing the character.
我觉得我能看出不仅仅是帕姆很高兴吉姆回来。我当时想，哦天哪，我的对手戏演员面对面了。是的。我们确实一起拍了几场戏，这总是很美好的。这总是很美好的。所以在最后一季里我有一种回家的感觉，就像我回到了我的……回到了这个人身边，你知道吗？那个和我一起经历这一切的人。你完全没说错。这不仅仅是在演角色。
It was like actually doing scenes with you. And Angela, you were pretty good too. It was fun to see you as well. Well, you know what, in re-watching season nine, which we haven't seen these episodes since they've aired, you know, And I thought it was so sweet. I had forgotten how much Dwight is missing Jim. And that was so sweet to watch play out. I mean, obviously he always acts out like horribly, but he's missing Jim. Those were always my favorite.
而是真的在跟你演对手戏。安吉拉，你其实演得也挺好的。看你演也挺有趣的。嗯，你知道吗，在重看第九季时，这些剧集自播出以来我们都没看过了，你知道的。我觉得太甜蜜了。我差点忘了雨果（Dwight）有多想念吉姆。看着这一幕上演真的太甜蜜了。显然他总是表现得很糟糕，但他确实想念吉姆。那些一直都是我最喜欢的。
Like the things, because I know Rain, I think on some of the bloopers, he did do this thing with his face that I don't know, I could feel it. I didn't even have to see it. I would feel it and start laughing. And we had such a fun chemistry, but I loved the scenes where we connected and that we were there for each other instead of, you know, going after each other all the time. That stuff was, that was great. Oh, man, guys, this is bringing up too many memories. Holy smoke. up too many memories. Holy smoke. I know. It is. Well, there's one thing I want to bring up with you, John, which is we haven't gotten there yet in our rewatch, but I remember we had this big discussion with Greg where we were like, okay, we kind of know what's gonna kind of drive a wedge between
比如那些事情，因为我知道雷恩（Rainn），我想在某些NG镜头里，他确实用他的脸做了那个表情，我不知道，我能感觉得到。我甚至都不用看。我只要感觉到它就会笑出来。我们有着非常有趣的化学反应，但我最喜欢那些我们产生连接、彼此支持的场景，而不是总是针锋相对。那些内容真的是太棒了。哦，天哪，伙计们，这勾起了太多回忆。天呐。
Jim and Pam, this long distance job and this sort of disagreement about whether or not this is a good idea in general. But what's going to bring them back together? And I remember saying, Greg, we have to reveal what is in the teapot note before we end this show. Like people need to know this. But like, how do you do that? Like how, why we couldn't figure it out. I was like, please, please, please. And I remember clear as day, John, we were in the break room for some reason, and it was a Monday. And you came in and you were doing your little shoulder
勾起了太多回忆。天呐。我知道。确实如此。嗯，有一件事我想和你们谈谈，约翰，我们重看到那集还没到那儿，但我记得我们和格雷格有过一次重大讨论，当时我们说，好吧，我们大概知道是什么在吉姆和帕姆之间打入楔子了，是这份异地工作，以及对于这是否是个好主意的不满。但什么能让他们重新走到一起呢？我记得我说过，格雷格，我们必须在剧集结束前揭晓茶壶纸条里写了什么。人们需要知道这个。但问题是，怎么做呢？怎么做……我们当时想不出来。我当时就说，求求你了，求求你了。我记得非常清楚，约翰，不知为什么我们在休息室里，那是星期一。你走进来，做着你那种
shake that you do when you get real excited about an idea. Still hasn't changed. And you were like, you guys, you guys, you guys, I was talking to Emily this weekend. Listen, listen. OK, what is the one thing that this couple has that, like, you wish you could have as a couple? They have their whole love story on tape.
兴奋时会有的标志性耸肩动作。到现在还没变。你当时说，伙计们，伙计们，伙计们，我这周末跟艾米莉聊天了。听着，听着。好吧，这对情侣身上有什么是别的伴侣都渴望拥有的？他们有他们完整的爱情故事录像带。
Like, this documentary crew has been documenting this love story. Like, I remember you saying, Jenna, could you imagine if you could go back to that first date with Lee and, like, someone had taped it and you could watch yourselves on that first date? Wouldn't you just like lose it? And I was like, oh my God, I would lose it. And you're like, what if Jim asked the documentary crew to put together the footage and he shows it to Pam? And I was like, oh my God, I would be a puddle. And then we just all got so excited about this idea.
就像，这个纪录片摄制组一直在记录这段爱情故事。就像我记得你说的，詹娜，你能想象如果你能回到和李的那个第一次约会，有人把它录下来了，你可以看着你们在那个第一次约会的录像吗？你会不会当场抓狂？我当时就想，哦天哪，我绝对会抓狂。然后你说，如果吉姆让纪录片摄制组把这些素材剪辑到一起，然后放给帕姆看呢？我当时就想，哦天哪，我会感动得一塌糊涂。然后我们所有人都对这个创意兴奋不已。
That sounds like a blunt idea. That sounds like blunt genius right there. And I just stole it. I just stole it. Well, that was the thing. You were like, Emily was like, what's the thing that this couple has that no other couple has? So smart. Oh my God. It's so smart. It was so smart. By the way, I remember when they were putting that together, I was so excited to see it too because we didn't know what they were
这听起来真是一个绝妙的主意。这简直就是绝顶天才的主意。而我只是偷了这个创意。我只是偷了这个创意。好吧，事情就是这样。当时的情况是，艾米莉问，这对情侣拥有什么其他情侣没有的东西？太聪明了。哦天哪。太聪明了。这真的太聪明了。顺便说一句，我记得他们当时在剪辑那个片段时，我也超级兴奋想看，因为我们不知道他们会把
going to put together in that whole situation. Oh God, it was so much. It was so much. What episode is that? I don't know. We're not there yet. It's very close to the end though. I mean, it might be like even the one of the two before the finale. Guys, do you remember, again, maybe I'm remembering wrong, cause I'm 98 years old, but, um, do you remember that like we, Greg hadn't talked to Steve like officially about the end. do you remember that, like, we, Greg hadn't talked to Steve, like, officially about the end?
什么样的素材剪进那个情境里。哦天哪，那太丰富了。那太丰富了。那是哪一集？我不知道。我们还没看到那儿。不过离大结局非常近了。我的意思是，可能就是大结局前的倒数第一或第二集。伙计们，还记得吗——也许我记错了，因为我都98岁了——但是，你们还记得格雷格当时没有正式和史蒂夫谈过关于结局的事吗？
Do you remember this? Yeah. Like, he had thrown it out to Steve in the beginning. Am I remembering this right? And then, like, as we got closer to the end, it was like, so is Steve gonna, and I remember he was shooting something. It wasn't like he didn't want to do it. It was just like scheduling and all that.
你们还记得这个吗？是的。就像他一开始跟史蒂夫提过一样。我没记错吧？然后，随着我们接近尾声，情况就变成了，史蒂夫到底会不会……我记得他当时在拍别的戏。并不是他不想演。只是档期之类的问题。
And then, but Greg, because he's so nice, wasn't pressuring anyone. And then that the whole Steve reveal was kind of a big reveal for us too. Like his appearance was huge. Yeah. He told us like very close to when it was going to happen. He, I think he got you, me and Rain aside, John, and he told us a couple days before, but then he swore us to secrecy. And Jenna told me that Rain pulled her aside and said, Jenna, you cannot tell Angela. Like, I was so scared.
然后，但格雷格人太好了，没有给任何人施加压力。然后整个史蒂夫的回归对我们来说也是一个巨大的惊喜。他的出现太震撼了。是的。他离这件事发生很近的时候才告诉我们。他，我想他把我和你、雷恩拉到一边，约翰，他在几天前告诉了我们，但他让我们发誓保密。詹娜告诉我，雷恩把她拉到一边说，詹娜，你绝对不能告诉安吉拉。当时我吓坏了。
Don't do it. I didn't know. The first time I saw Steve, I was walking to Hair and Makeup, and I forget who I was walking with, but they were like, you know, Steve is here? And I was like, shut up. Whatever. What were you talking about?
别说。我当时根本不知道。我第一次见到史蒂夫时，我正走向化妆间，我忘了当时跟谁一起走的，但他们说，你知道史蒂夫来了吗？我说，闭嘴。少来。你们在说什么？
You didn't know until the day? I opened the door, and he was in the chair. And he turned around, shut up, whatever. What were you talking about? You didn't know until the day? I opened the door and he was in the chair and he turned around and he goes, and, and I was like, ah, I was like, what's happening? That rain scene where I say I can't do it, oh my God. That was so well done. Yeah. So smart. So great. So smart.
你直到当天才知道？我打开门，他正坐在椅子上。他转过身来，闭嘴，少来。你们在说什么？你直到当天才知道？我打开门，他正坐在椅子上，他转过身说，然后，当时我就，啊，我就想，这怎么回事？雷恩那场我说我做不到的戏，哦天哪。演得太棒了。是的。太聪明了。太棒了。太聪明了。
And when I say well done, I mean, I had nothing to do with it. Like how great that we were on a show that the writing was so good that it was like, it was like Christmas morning every day you read a script, you were like, oh, oh my God. We just got to show up and play. It was the best. Yeah. Well, that leads me to this question, John, if you could go back and relive a moment from
我说的演得好，意思是，这跟我没关系。我们能参演一部剧本如此优秀的剧集是多么幸运，每天读剧本就像过圣诞节的早晨一样，你会想，哦，哦天哪。我们只需要出场表演就行了。这感觉太棒了。是的。好吧，这让我想到了这个问题，约翰，如果你能回到过去，重新经历你在《办公室》里的一段时光，那会是什么时候？
your time on the office, what would it be? Oh, man. It wouldn't be one moment. It would be a routine. It would be, I loved so much coming in every morning and seeing the entirety of the crew and cast that we would come on and we hadn't really started the day when we were catching up over the week about what happened over the weekend. And every single crew member was our family, every single cast member was our family. And I genuinely mean it when I say I miss it as much as I miss real family stuff and real friends stuff.
哦，天哪。不会是一个瞬间。而会是一种日常。我最喜欢每天早晨走进片场，看到所有的剧组人员和演员齐聚一堂，我们在正式开始一天的工作前，先聊聊各自的周末是怎么度过的。每一个剧组人员都是我们的家人，每一个演员都是我们的家人。我是发自内心地说，我想念他们，就像我想念真正的家人和真正的朋友一样。
I mean, I don't know, I don't know, maybe a lot of people have this. I don't know if people get to have and create de facto families separate from their own realities, you know what I mean? At work or whatever. But it wasn't just work. It was like we became this fake real family.
我的意思是，我不知道，我不知道，也许很多人都有这种体验。我不知道人们是否能在现实生活之外建立并创造出事实上的家庭，你知道我的意思吗？在工作或其他地方。但这不仅仅是工作。我们变成了这样一个虚幻又真实的家庭。
And it was really those in-between moments. Those catching up moments were just the best. From talking to you guys and hearing about you know new relationships or oh my god I think I'm pregnant all that stuff but also like crew members and laughing and Steve coming for a couple days you know he might have been shooting something else those one couple of times then he'd tell me a bit that he was doing and or when he pretended to fake vomit and that was my favorite bit I've ever seen in my life ever. Like, just little stuff like that.
真的就是那些片场间隙的时刻。那些叙旧的时刻才是最棒的。从和你们聊天，听到你们谈论新的恋情，或者“哦天哪，我觉得我怀孕了”之类的事情，还有剧组成员们的欢笑，史蒂夫来呆上几天——他当时可能在拍别的戏，抽空来那么一两次——然后他会跟我讲他正在做的即兴表演，或者当他假装呕吐时，那是我这辈子见过最喜欢的桥段。就像，仅仅是诸如此类的小事。
It was always the in-between moments for me that I think I remember the most. And certainly, only because you're on the last season, so I can say, the evil genius of Greg Daniels saying, we're going to shoot a scene where we're all going to poor Richards at the end. And we went out and we all hook, line, and sinkered that one. And we all went out and we're like, Oh yeah, of course we're going to poor Richard. No problem. And the whole cast kept going
对合金来说，我最怀念的总是那些间隙的时刻。当然，正因为你们现在演到最后一季了，所以我可以说，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）真是个邪恶的天才，他说，我们要拍一场戏，最后大家都要去“穷理查德酒吧”（Poor Richard's）。我们去了，所有人都毫无防备地跳进了这个圈套。我们都去了，还说，“哦，对，当然，我们要去穷理查德酒吧。没问题。”然后整个剧组一直在
in and out of the door like four times. And so we were out in the lobby waiting for him to call reset and we were laughing and joking. And when we came back in, I don't know how he did it, but he assembled the entirety of the crew. And we came, I'm like choking up, just talking about it. But then when you come back in and you see like your TV dad and all of your family waiting there and clapping, and he said, that's the end of the office. And I, I think I black, I was like, I think I like the color black came out of my mouth. Like I, it was just the scariest, most beautiful, horrific moment of my life.
进进出出那扇门大约四次。所以我们当时在门厅等着他喊重拍，大家还在那儿有说有笑。当我们走回房间时，我不知道他是怎么做到的，他把全体剧组成员都召集了起来。我们走进来，我一说这个就要哽咽了。但当你走回来，看到你的电视老爸和所有的家人都在那儿等着并为你鼓掌，他说，“《办公室》到此结束。”然后我，我想我直接，我感觉我的脑子一片空白。就像，我感觉我的嘴里吐出了黑色的气体。那绝对是我这生中最可怕、最美好、最震撼的时刻。
And then 30 minutes later, I took the Dunder Mifflin sign, which I think I've always lied to Greg that I didn't take it, but I did. I stole it. It's one of my favorite memories of our last day was watching you try to put it in the back of your car. I was walking through the parking lot and I was like, is that the, oh, it's the Dunder Mifflin sign.
然后在30分钟后，我拿走了邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的标志牌，我想我一直对格雷格撒谎说我没拿，但我其实拿了。我把它偷走了。我关于最后一天最美好的回忆之一，就是看着你试图把它塞进你的车后座。我当时正穿过停车场，心想，那是……哦，那是邓德·米夫林的标志牌。
Yeah, and I was like, don't look over here. Nothing's happening here. It wasn't quite dark enough. So it just looked like I was putting a body in a car. And then I remember Greg came up to me at the end party and was like, hey, we've been looking for the sign. Do you know where it is? And it was literally like confessing to my dad.
是的，当时我就想，别往这边看。这里什么都没发生。当时天还不够黑。所以看起来就像我在往车里塞一具尸体。然后我记得格雷格在杀青派对上走到我面前说，嘿，我们一直在找那个标志牌。你知道它在哪儿吗？这简直就像向我老爸坦白一样。
And I went, no, nope, no. And he goes, oh, that was the one thing I wanted. And I was like, oh boy, oh God. I never told anyone I saw you putting it in the car. Well, now you did. Now you told everyone. And I was dressed like a cat burglar. John, it's really funny to me because the moment
我说，不，没有，不知道。他说，哦，那是唯一我想留作纪念的东西。我说，哦天哪，哦上帝。我从来没告诉任何人我看到你把它塞进车里了。好吧，现在你说了。现在你把所有人都抖出来了。而且我当时还穿得像个江洋大盗。约翰，这让我觉得很有趣，因为你最希望重新经历的时刻，仅仅是和剧组演员及工作人员聊聊各自周末的时刻……
that you would most wish to relive, just the moment of talking to the cast and crew about their weekend... I know what you're gonna say, Jenna. I know what you're gonna say. Is Rain's nightmare. What? Do you remember when we were all sitting on set once and it was like a Tuesday and all of a sudden Rain, out of nowhere, he bursts out and he goes, attention!
我知道你想说什么，詹娜。我知道你想说什么。那是雷恩的噩梦。什么？还记得有一次我们都坐在片场，那是星期二，突然之间，雷恩毫无征兆地爆发了，他大喊：注意！
Attention! I need everyone's attention. Listen to me. From now on, we only ask, how was your weekend on Mondays? You get one day, you get one day to ask me, how are you and how was your weekend? And then it's enough. I can't take it anymore. I cannot take the questions anymore.
注意！我需要所有人的注意。听我说。从现在开始，我们只能在星期一问“你周末过得怎么样”。你们只有一天时间，你们只有一天时间来问我“你好吗，你周末过得怎么样”。然后就够了。我再也受不了了。我再也受不了这些问题了。
We were all like... It's like a Curb Your Enthusiasm episode. It was. And I remember Dale was right by him and he all like, it's like a curb your enthusiasm episode. And I remember Dale, Dale was right by him. And he was like, jeez. And rain really talks about this. We've had full conversations with him and he's like, remember that day? I told everyone, don't ask me about the weekend on Tuesdays. It just like short circuited rain would not want to revisit that. He would not.
我们当时都……这就像是《抑制热情》里的情节。确实是。我记得戴尔（Dale）就在他旁边，他当时就说，这就像是《抑制热情》里的情节。我记得戴尔，戴尔就在他旁边。他当时说，天哪。雷恩真的经常谈起这个。我们曾跟他深入聊过，他说，还记得那一天吗？我告诉所有人，星期二别问我周末的事。这简直让雷恩直接短路了，他绝对不想重温那一幕。他才不要。
By the way, you know, another thing that you guys were both involved in was, I think, yeah, I think I said to Greg, do you mind if I make some sort of documentary about the end? And my buddy Danny shot it. And I remember he showed me the rough cut of all of us saying goodbye to the office. And you guys all had the same reaction, which is he was like, so what do you think about the end of the office? And you guys, both of you went about the end of the office? And you guys, both of you went the end of the, wow. It was just, we all, we all couldn't even get past the first question. It was too much. It was a beautiful, beautiful time. It really was.
顺便说一句，你知道吗，你们俩都参与的另一件事是，我想，是的，我想我当时对格雷格说，你介意我拍一部关于剧集杀青的纪录片吗？我的朋友丹尼拍了它。我记得他给我看我们所有人告别办公室的粗剪版。你们当时的反应都一样，就是他问，“那么你对《办公室》的结束有什么看法？”然后你们，你们两个都说：“关于《办公室》的结束，呃，哇。”我们当时都，我们甚至都无法越过第一个问题。情绪实在太饱满了。那是一段极其美好的时光。真的。
It really was. And you guys will have to live through that again, right? Pretty soon. In about 14 weeks or whatever. Yeah. And you guys, are you going to run it back? Are you just gonna like people watch the show over and over? Why wouldn't you just do this again and find new things in episodes? People are writing in and saying this to us, John.
真的。你们俩也得重新经历这一切，对吧？很快。大约在14周左右之后吧。是的。伙计们，你们打算重温它吗？还是说你们只是像普通观众一样一遍又一遍地看这部剧？为什么不重新做一次这个播客，并在剧集中发现新的东西呢？人们写信给我们时就是这么说的，约翰。
They're just like, do it again. I would. I mean, we can't. Do it again, let's talk about it in a different way. There's, I think, things we missed. I mean, clearly Presente will tell the same stories. They would care. This has been so much fun.
他们总是说，再做一次吧。我会的。我的意思是，我们不能。再做一次吧，让我们换个角度聊聊。我觉得有些事情我们错过了。显然，普伦特（Presente）也会讲同样的故事。他们在乎。这真的太有趣了。
So much fun. Is it over already? No, I'm going to bring us home with our call sheet questions that were on the back of the call sheet. God, I missed your accent. I'm going to bring it home with my split hands. Sorry, both of my sisters from Texas are here visiting and so I'm, I mean, I can tell. Yes, I know they've been here a few days. Here we go. The call sheet questions. Number one, what was your first entertainment job? What does that entail? I think I was an extra. Well, actually I remember because my first job was an extra in a
太有趣了。已经结束了吗？不，我要用通告单背面的通告单问题来收尾了。天哪，我怀念你的口音了。我要用我分裂的手来收尾了。抱歉，我的两个来自德克萨斯州的姐姐刚好来拜访，所以我，我的意思是，听得出来。是的，我知道她们来这儿几天了。我们开始吧。通告单问题。第一题，你的第一份娱乐工作是什么？那份工作具体要做什么？我想我当时是个临时演员。嗯，其实我记得，因为我的第一份工作是在一个
insurance commercial that then they bumped me up to featured extra because I became the cashier. And the only reason why I remember that so vividly is because the woman who is checking out who was the lead of the commercial was Margot Martindale, who I later was in a movie called The Hollers, and she played my mom. Oh my gosh. Yeah. And then they gave me my sag card that day. And I remember her saying something to the effect of like, yeah, you better. That's right. You will give it to him because he's doing great. I think you're doing great. And I was like, Oh my God.
保险广告里当临时演员，然后他们把我提拔为特约临时演员，因为我成了收银员。我之所以能把这件事记得这么清楚，唯一的原因是因为那个结账的女人，也就是广告的主演是玛戈·马丁代尔（Margo Martindale），我后来和她一起演了一部电影叫《霍勒斯》（The Hollers），她在里面扮演我妈妈。哦天哪。是的。然后他们那天给了我演员工会卡（SAG card）。我记得她当时说了一些类似于“对，你最好这样。没错。你会把卡给他的，因为他表现得很棒。我觉得你表现得很棒”之类的话。当时我就想，哦天哪。
Did you guys talk about that story when you did the movie together? Oh yeah. I think she probably had something to do with getting me my SAG card. So yeah, she's, she is the most wonderful, wonderful. Have you guys worked with her? I have not. No, big fan, big fan would probably not be cool around her. Get there quick. Would try. Okay, number two. Do you play a musical instrument? I did play a musical instrument. I played trumpet for nine years and probably could not do that at all right now. My lips would fall off. But I have been desperately trying to learn piano and guitar, and it's going on 15 years now. So I can play let it be.
你们一起拍电影时聊过这个故事吗？哦，是的。我想她可能在帮我拿到演员工会卡这件事上出了力。所以，是的，她是，她是最棒的，最棒的。你们和她合作过吗？我没有。没有，我是她的超级粉丝，超级粉丝，在她面前可能无法保持冷静。快去吧。我会努力的。好的，第二题。你会演奏乐器吗？我以前会演奏乐器。我吹了九年小号，现在大概完全吹不出来了。我的嘴唇会掉下来的。但我一直在拼命尝试学习钢琴和吉他，这已经持续了15年了。所以我可以弹奏《Let It Be》。
I remember you had a beautiful little upright piano, remember? That's right. And I felt like you played it really well. So maybe it's more than 15, Anne. Sorry. Can you play any song? Yes, I can play some Beatles stuff. I can play that amazing stay. Rihanna, Rihanna sings stay.
我记得你有一架漂亮的小号立式钢琴，记得吗？没错。我觉得你弹得非常好。所以可能不止15年了，安恩。抱歉。你能弹任何曲子吗？是的，我可以弹一些披头士的歌。我可以弹那首神奇的《Stay》。蕾哈娜，蕾哈娜唱的《Stay》。
Yeah, they make me happy. I love it. Okay, number three, what's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved? Oh, man, so many. I've been so lucky in the last couple of years on Jack Ryan to travel all these different wild places. But I gotta say something about Paris has stolen a piece of my heart forever.
是的，它们让我快乐。我太喜欢了。好的，第三题，你去过哪个让你无比热爱的地方？哦，天哪，有太多了。这几年我拍《杰克·莱恩》时非常幸运，去过所有这些不同且狂野的地方。但我必须说，巴黎有一点永远偷走了我的心。
There's something about it where when I close my eyes, I feel like it's still in the 1920s and I'm just hearing jazz for the first time and like all these epic writers are walking the streets. And I did a very nerdy thing in Paris, which I highly recommend. I read a movable feast at the same cafes that Hemingway wrote them at, and it was full nerdville.
那里的某种特质，每当我闭上眼睛，我都觉得它依然停留在20世纪20年代，我仿佛第一次听到爵士乐，所有这些传奇作家都在街头漫步。我在巴黎做了一件非常书呆子气的事情，我强烈推荐。我在海明威写书的那些咖啡馆里读了《流动的盛宴》，简直是书呆子本呆。
I had the best time ever. John, I read a movable feast because you told me how much you loved it. I've never told you that. No way, I thought, oh my God. Years ago, you were like, oh, A Moveable Feast is so good. So I went and got it and I'd never read it. I still have the paperback on my nightstand,
我度过了有生以来最棒的时光。约翰，我读《流动的盛宴》就是因为你告诉我你有多爱它。我从来没跟你说过这事。不可能，我当时想，哦天哪。多年前，你曾说，哦，《流动的盛宴》太棒了。所以我去买了一本，我以前从没读过。现在那本平装书还在我的床头柜上，
like in my stack of favorite books. And it's so amazing, but I've never told you that. Isn't that amazing? Yes, it's so good. Oh my God. Okay, next question is, what do you like to do on the weekends Oh my god. Oh, okay. Next question is What do you like to do on the weekends? Anything with my kids honestly, it's just it's so much fun and I've been shooting in London recently and flying back on the weekends to see them and
就在我最喜欢的书堆里。这太神奇了，但我从来没跟你说过。这难道不神奇吗？是的，太棒了。哦天哪。好的，下一个问题是，你周末喜欢做什么？哦天哪。哦……好的，下一个问题是，你周末喜欢做什么？老实说，只要和我的孩子们在一起做什么都行，真的太有趣了。我最近一直在伦敦拍戏，周末会飞回来见她们。
So as soon as I get back, it's just like I said, it's it sounds like I'm still promoting the movie But it's true like anything to get around their imagination or be dressed up in something or have my makeup done and hair done, that's the perfect day for me. Okay, don't cry. Number five. What is your favorite midnight snack? Ooh, that's tough.
所以一回到家，就像我刚才说的，听起来我好像还在宣传电影，但这是真的，只要能参与她们的想象力，或者穿上某种服装，或者让她们帮我化妆弄头发，对她们来说就是最完美的一天。好吧，别哭。第四题。你最喜欢的午夜小吃是什么？哦，这很难选。
Mine's a sliding scale, because it's leftovers. I'm a huge, there's something about the refrigerator that makes whatever meal was made Mine's a sliding scale because it's leftovers. There's something about the refrigerator that makes whatever meal was made, definitely not by me, better. I will say I have Emily's blessing on that, especially any Bolognese or stew or something like that. It just gets better and better just sitting in the refrigerator. I'm a leftovers guy. And and usually a
我的是一个滑动区间，因为是剩菜。我超级喜欢，冰箱里总有某种魔力，能把之前做好的——我的是一个滑动区间，因为是剩菜。冰箱里总有某种魔力，能把之前做好的饭菜（绝对不是我做的）变得更好吃。我要说，艾米莉对这一点表示赞同，尤其是任何肉酱（Bolognese）或炖菜之类的东西。放在冰箱里放着，味道只会越来越好。我是个剩菜爱好者。而且
two or three portioner guy like, Oh, I'll just have one more. You say that you don't cook, but do you have a go to meal? Like do you have if you had to cook for an occasion? Do you have a thing? Like I feel like everybody has one one meal, right? Have I not told you this story? It was Mother's Day. And it was my gift to my wife, which makes me sound like, guess what I did? It's just, that's stupid. But we actually had a bet, this is a true story. We had a bet that Leonardo DiCaprio,
通常是会吃上两三份的那种人，比如，哦，我再吃一份。你说你不会做饭，但你有没有拿手菜？比如如果你必须为某个场合做饭，你有什么招牌菜吗？我觉得每个人都有一道拿手菜，对吧？我没讲过这个故事吗？那是母亲节。这是我送给我老婆的礼物，听起来就像在说，猜猜我做了什么？这挺蠢的。但我们当时其实打了个赌，这是个真事。我们打赌莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，
I said he was younger than me because I said that cherubic face could not be as old as I am, which is dirt. And she said, he's definitely a couple of years older than you, I said, that's not true. And I said, I I'll bet. She goes, how about this? If you win, I forget what hers was. I think it back in the day, it was like, you can play Call of Duty for one full day. How nerdy that I was like, yes, yes. And then she said, and if you lose, you have to cook me my first meal. And I said, fine. And so I lost, which is, I still can't believe it.
我说他比我年轻，因为我觉得他那张娃娃脸不可能像我一样年纪这么大（老得像泥土一样）。她说，他绝对比你大好几岁。我说，才不是呢。我说，我跟你赌。她说，这样吧，如果你赢了，我忘了她的赌注是什么了。我觉得在当时，大概是“你可以一整天都玩《使命召唤》”。我当时怎么会觉得“好呀，好呀”这么书呆子气呢。然后她说，如果你输了，你得给我做第一顿饭。我说，行。结果我输了，这至今让我难以置信。
Leo, you're 18 in my book. So the first meal I cooked became one of my old standbys, which is coca van. Coca van. What? Yeah. Just coca van is your meal? I mean, I thought you were gonna say I made meatloaf.
小李子，你在我心里永远18岁。所以我做的第一顿饭成了我的招牌菜之一，也就是红酒炖牛肉（Coq au Vin）。红酒炖牛肉。什么？是的。红酒炖牛肉居然是你的拿手菜？我的意思是，我还以为你会说我做了肉饼。
Nope. Wow. No, this is my plug for Ina. I just went straight to you, cause I know Em's a huge fan of Ina's. So I went straight to her book and opened some pages of, and I was like, what do I get after here? And I wanted to impress her
不。哇。不，这是我要给英娜（Ina Garten）打广告。我直接去找她了，因为我知道艾米莉是英娜的超级粉丝。所以我直接翻开她的书，随便翻了几页，然后心想，从这里开始我能学做什么？我想给她留下深刻印象，
because it was the first time I was gonna cook her anything that wasn't like grilled cheese or scrambled eggs. Sure. So I went full coca van and I said, you have to be really honest. And she said, it's fantastic. Keep making it. So now it's one of my standbys. That's amazing.
因为那是我第一次给她做饭，做一些不只是烤奶酪或炒鸡蛋的东西。当然。所以我直接上了红酒炖牛肉，我说，你必须老实说。她说，太棒了。继续做。所以现在它成了我的拿手菜之一。这太神奇了。
That's impressive. I'm happy to cook it for you guys. We'll eat it. I know is the go-to. I know is the go-to. Every Christmas morning we have to have Ina Gartens. It's like a raspberry crumble thing. For the listeners who can't see Jenna's fingers are moving, which means we're almost there.
太令人印象深刻了。我很乐意为你们做。我们会吃的。我知道那是首选。我知道那是首选。每年圣诞节早晨我们都必须吃英娜·加滕的菜。就像是一种树莓脆皮甜点。对于听不到声音的听众，詹娜的手指正在动，这意味着我们快聊完了。
We're, well, we're crumbling it. We're crumbling the pastry in our fingers is what's happening. You can see it. Well, guys, I married a baker, so, you know. Oh, boy, yeah. None of my pants fit me anymore. Oh, my God.
我们在，嗯，我们在把它捏碎。我们在用手指捏碎酥皮，这就是正在发生的事。你能看出来的。好吧，伙计们，我嫁给了一个面包师，所以，你知道的。哦，天哪，是的。我的裤子现在没有一条合身的了。哦，天哪。
But I do eat some delicious food. It is a wonderful thing. I will say, I love your Instagram when you show the baked goods and the things that you guys have eaten together. It's a problem for me. It's a problem. No, I mean, that's fantastic.
但我确实吃到了很多美味的食物。这是一件美妙的事。我要说，我非常喜欢你的Instagram，当你展示烘焙食品和你们一起吃的东西时。这对我是个折磨。这是个折磨。不，我是说，那太棒了。
But it's great. Well, then she drives the leftovers over to my house. I do. Like to get them out of her house. I've got to get them out. I love how she says you drive it over as if it's like a trailer that takes that many baked goods.
但这很棒。然后她会把剩菜开车送到我家。我确实会。为了把它们从她家里清出去。我得把它们弄走。我喜欢她说的“你开车送过去”，听起来好像运送那么多烘焙食品需要一辆拖车似的。
But it is a little bit. She's like, here's seven dozen lemon drop cookies. I want them out of my house. If you live within driving distance of me, chances are I've left you baked goods on your porch. Like so many people are like, Ange, what is this? I'm like, just take it. You just throw cookies at people as they're walking their dog.
但其实差不多。她就像是，“这里有七打柠檬糖霜饼干。我希望它们从我家里消失。”如果你住在离我开车能到的范围内，我大概率在你的门廊上留过烘焙食品。好多人都会问，“安吉拉，这是什么？”我就说，“拿去吧。”你简直就像是在人们遛狗时把饼干朝他们砸过去。
She does. Take it. In it. Oh, John, it's been so fun to reconnect with you. throw cookies at people as they're walking their dog. Oh, John, it's been so fun to reconnect with you. We're so excited for your movie. Everybody. It comes out this Friday, May 17th. Go bring tissues. Weep with us.
她真的会。拿去吧。给。哦，约翰，能和你重新联系上真的太有趣了。把饼干砸向遛狗的人。哦，约翰，能和你重新联系上真的太有趣了。我们为你感到无比兴奋。各位。电影将于本周五，即5月17日上映。去带上纸巾。和我们一起哭吧。
Yes. We're going to share all about it in our Insta stories. We'll put swipe up so you can go find it. John, we're so happy for you. I don't even know how to swipe up. So you guys are way ahead of me, way ahead of you guys. Honestly, I think I said this to you again in the COVID thing.
是的。我们会在Ins快拍里分享关于它的一切。我们会放上上滑链接，这样你们就能找到了。约翰，我们为你感到由衷的高兴。我甚至不知道怎么上滑。所以你们比我懂得多，比你们懂得多。老实说，我想我之前在那个疫情连线里就跟你说过，
It brings me so much joy that you guys are doing this show and that you guys are doing it together and that you guys are seeming to have so much fun doing it. I mean, this is not a job for you. It is very obvious. And boy, are you bringing joy to a lot of people and I just, I love it. Thank you for having me do this today. This is great.
看到你们俩在做这个节目，你们在一起做这个节目，而且你们做的时候看起来那么开心，这给我带来了极大的快乐。我的意思是，这对你们来说不是一份工作。这太明显了。天哪，你们给这么多人都带来了快乐，我太喜欢了。谢谢你今天来参加我们的节目。这太棒了。
Aw, John, well, you know, working with my best friend brings me so much joy, and then we get to reconnect and see you and air hug. Yes, air hugs, John. Oh, how fun was that? I just love him and I'm so proud of him and I can't wait to see this movie. Same lady. John, we love you. We are here for you. Thanks for being on the podcast again and go check out IF it's in theaters this Friday, May 17. See you next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
哦，约翰，你知道的，和我的好朋友一起工作给我带来了无穷的快乐，然后我们又能重新联系上你、看到你，隔空拥抱。是的，隔空拥抱，约翰。哦，多有趣啊！我太爱他了，我为他感到无比骄傲，我迫不及待想看这部电影了。同感，女士。约翰，我们爱你。我们永远支持你。谢谢你再次做客播客，大家快去看看《IF》吧，本周五，5月17日各大影院上映。下周见。下周见。感谢收听办公室女士。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Office Ladies》由 Earwulf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的高级制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。